hey it's alex and today i'm going to
show you how to make my chicken cordon
bleu bake
[Music]
cold on blue so this recipe is kind of a
cross between a classic chicken cordon
bleu
and a beef wellington so i have the
classic elements of a chicken cordon
bleu but instead of the breading outside
i did a pastry outside so the chicken
cordon bleu inside is all very classic
and traditional so you can choose to
season your breasts individually but i
just threw them on the bowl and seasoned
that all in there just to make it a
little easier and faster so you're going
to want to pound out your chicken breast
until it's pretty thin this will help
you to roll it in the next step if you
happen to have a metal mallet that's a
really easy way to make sure your
chicken is pounded out properly but
there's other tools you can use flying
around in your house to make sure you
get that thin piece of chicken i use a
wooden spoon it takes a little extra
effort but it still works and you could
also use a cast iron skillet so i
layered this with a double layer of the
cheese
just to make sure you get that extra
ooey gooey cheesy center and actually
made for a pretty good visual at the end
[Music]
so to make the rolling process easier i
hung my chicken on a piece of plastic
wrap so once you roll it up you're able
to encase that in the plastic and roll
it even tighter you want a really tight
seal so rolling it back and forth will
help you achieve that you kind of want
to get all the air you can out of it and
tightly roll it and seal it on the edges
so they have a nice
tight
little chicken
well chicken they look like little like
piggies
so putting the chicken back in the
fridge is an important step to allow the
chicken to kind of firm up and hold its
shape so now for the outside i used puff
pastry because that is classic to a beef
wellington i trim the puffed pastry down
just because with the individual wrapped
chickens you don't want to have too much
extra puff pastry
because it'll just be like too bready
and also it might not cook like all the
way through if there's a lot of extra
kind of bunched up right there so
classically in a wellington the puff
pastry is brushed with english mustard
you could really use any like mustard
variety that you like like a dijon or
just a regular yellow mustard but
english mustard has a ton of flavor and
a really bright vibrant yellow color and
you can usually find it at most grocery
stores so once your chickens are cooled
and set pop that right on the puff
pastry and give it a wrap now again if
you have too much extra puff pastry trim
that off and then you can tuck the sides
under and kind of fix it so it looks
really nice
the egg wash will help your puff pastry
get really nice and brown and golden
color once it's baked so then it's time
to get a little fancy with it so in
order to create a nice design on the
outside i took a fork and kind of drew
marks in the puff pastry itself so i did
the lines one way and then i went back
and did it diagonally so it had a nice
kind of diamond pattern on the puff
pastry so once it baked it looks really
nice and pretty then hit it with a
little more salt
and you're ready to bake salt bae that
ish
so you want to bake your rolls until of
course the chicken is cooked through now
this chicken will actually cook pretty
fast because it's pounded out so thin so
it just won't take as long to cook as
like a full piece of chicken breast
but you also are looking for a really
deep golden brown color on the puff
pastry to make sure it's all the way
cooked through pounding out the chicken
breasts and rolling it up like this will
help you get that really beautiful
spiral center that every chicken corn on
blue should have also what's great about
using the puff pastry as opposed to a
classic chicken cordon bleu breading is
that it's so much cleaner breading is
often pretty messy since you have like a
lot going on with the egg and the bread
crumbs and the flour
but this you get it all in one go and
no mess no fuss
it's what i like
this dish is also super show stopping
it's a great dish for a dinner party
they're pretty big so you might not need
to eat the whole thing but they look
really fancy and they taste even better
and they're also so cute look at them
they're like little
i don't know what a good word for that i
keep doing this
they're just so cute
[Music]
you